from compact functions
so this is joint work with tabanjan
so let's rewind back to before 2013 uh
crypto land i mean it was a nice
beautiful place right we had
accomplished so much you know we could
do information 3d crypto we still can uh
you know we we accomplished public
encryption zero knowledge npcs
signatures even abe and even fhe right
beautiful i mean amazing works and uh
i mean something we should be really
proud of and they're all still very
active areas of research okay but then
in 2013 uh this happened
indistinguishability of fescation came
around and uh all hell broke loose
yeah so one active line of research that
has emerged since then is essentially
building crypto from i o and usually
some other assumption like wonder
functions and this pretty much started
from the work of gorga tunnel and then
popularized by science waters
and there have been many many many works
since then
if you look closely they're all you know
encoded in there
but just to give you a sample i mean
functional encryption deniable
encryption round optimal mpc and so on
and so forth you know even impossibility
results at this on the last talk so so
this has all been great but uh this begs
the question you know how about the
opposite direction right how about
building io
so the current state of appeals is
essentially this if you look at it i
mean all the solutions that we know are
all the candidates for io that we know
rely on multilinear maps right so you
can kind of roughly categorize them in
two in two different areas uh one uh
there's a sequence of works that uh show
how to get io and sometimes even vbb
virtual black box or kitchen uh in the
ideal model where you assume that the i
that the adversary is uh is is in the
ideal model uh on the other hand there
are also a couple of more recent works
uh by parcetal and gen priyatal who make
some more concrete assumptions on
multi-layer maps and then show how to
get io okay ahmed talked about the the
second work on the first day so i'll not
go to any details of this
let me just put them all together as you
know a sequence of works that makes some
assumptions on multi-layer maps
to get io
so i want to claim that this is a
somewhat unsatisfactory state of affairs
uh for multiple reasons
one it i think it's fair to say that our
understanding of security of
multilingual maps is still
still at a very early stage and this is
evidenced by several recent attacks on
multilingual maps um so that's one
the other is uh
we would like to just understand the
complexity of crypto of io in in the
cryptozoo right where does it stand how
does it relate to other other primitives
um
and you know uh it would be nice to have
some balance you know we have so many
outgoing arrows from io it would be nice
to have some incoming arrows as well so
so on that front uh we do know one
implication from uh multi-input function
encryption to
to i o
um
i'll talk about what is multi-input
function encryption more in more detail
later but you can just think of it as a
generalization of functional encryption
to multiple inputs or computing over
multiple ciphertexts
so one could argue that in its most
general form multi-input function
encryption is in fact as powerful if not
even more powerful than io so it's not
really clear how much light it shifts in
terms of basing i o on weaker on weaker
primitives
and in this talk we'll try to make some
more progress in this direction by
getting i o from
a single input function encryption a
specific form of it that we call compact
function encryption and we'll do this
via the route of multi-input functional
encryption
let me just add a disclaimer right away
that this is not a candidate
construction all known constructions of
compact functional encryption
already rely on i o but there is nothing
to say that this is inherent we could
hope to base it
on weaker primitives
we also have another implication
from randomized encoding for turing
machines to compact functional
encryption and at a very high level this
is essentially taking a non-compact
function encryption scheme and kind of
squishing it down to make it compact i
won't have time to talk about uh the
last one but in this talk i'll focus on
the on the top result going from compact
fee to io
okay
so let's recall what is functional
encryption
so when we think of encryption it's a
very
the standard function standard
encryption it's a very all or nothing
primitive right a sender can send an
encryption of some message x to a
receiver and if the receiver has a
secret key then it can decrypt and learn
the entire message x but in certain
scenarios we want more fine-grained
control over the over the data and
functional encryption provides exactly
this capability uh where now in addition
to sender receiver we also have a third
trusted party uh namely the key
generator who has a master secret key
and the receiver can request keys for
functions from this key generator and he
will return him a key soc which is tied
to the function f
and now using this decryption key the
receiver can directly learn the output
of f on x without learning x
and the security
definition is exactly this that an
adversarial receiver should not be able
to learn anything beyond f of x given
the secret key for f
so compact function encryption has the
additional requirement now that the
complexity of the encryption algorithm
should not depend upon the function
complexity or the complexity of the
function supported by the fe scheme
to make it more precise we want that the
runtime of the encryption algorithm on
some input x should only be a polynomial
in the security parameter and the size
of x okay this is actually a bit too
strong uh it would be okay if we have
some sublinear dependence on the size of
f i'll mention it later again but it's
just simple to think of complete
independence on the size of f
okay
so main result is i o for p slash poly
from sub exponentially secured public
key compact fe
and just to make it more concrete the
security model that we need for
the underlying fee scheme is just
selective security and we only want it
to support one key query so this is
really the minimal security model that
you would want for fe and
i didn't mention but
indistinguishability security
if you had adaptive that was only
probably secure is that also enough like
can i trade the sub-exponential
uh
no
no no
and uh let me also mention there's an
exciting concurrent work by nir and
vinod who actually get the exact same
result uh superficially it might look
slightly different but the actual
details are pretty much identical and
they also observe uh that actual
sublinear dependence on the size of f is
sufficient you don't need full
compactness and the same observation is
true for our result as well
okay and we also have some other results
on multi-input function encryption and
compactor fee i won't have time to talk
about them but you can see them in the
paper
okay so
let me just briefly survey what we know
about single key fe in terms of the size
of the encryption algorithm
so
from just public key encryption we do
know functional encryption schemes for
single key where the size of the
ciphertext or the running time of the
encryption grows with the size of the
function okay
if we go on to
make assuming lwe then we can also get
encryption schemes where the running
time of the encryption depends on the
function output length so not
necessarily on the entire function size
but on the output length
and now to overcome this uh output line
dependence the only constructions we
know so far rely on i o so they are
fully compact but they rely on i o
but let me just point out that these
results actually achieve something much
stronger than what we need they support
unbounded number of keys or unbounded
collision resistance we don't need it we
just need a single key okay
so the obvious open question from our
work is uh constructing compactor fee
from weaker tools um
let me just point out or i guess uh just
mention that even heuristic instructions
for compact fee would be nice again just
to improve our understanding of i o
and even though our construction uses
public key fe even getting a compact if
you scheme with a secret key would again
be interesting just from a heuristic
viewpoint okay
so let me jump to the technical details
so let me just restate the main result
what i'm going to show you is how to get
secret key multi-input fe for nre
functions from a public key compact f
scheme okay and why this is sufficient
because we have this theorem uh where uh
by goldbach at all who show how to get
io for n bit input functions from secret
key mifv for n array functions
okay so let me actually just first
briefly recall this theorem why why why
is it true and then i'll i'll go to the
construction of mife
so mife is really just a generalization
of fe to multiple inputs now we have
multiple senders who can encrypt their
respective inputs and send it to a
receiver and if the receiver has a key
for a function f then it can learn the
output of f on all the inputs together
okay and the security requirement again
would be that given this key you should
only learn the output of f on these
inputs and nothing else right let me
also just introduce some notation so
uh for each input and for each
ciphertext will just associate a
position so for example x1 will be the
first position input and similarly uh
the ciphertext x1 will be the first
position ciphertext and so on
and i'm also going to use the shorthand
mifi sub i to denote mife for ira
functions
okay
so let's see how to get i o from
mife for nrv functions
so if i want to obfuscate a function f
then it will consist of two main parts
the first one will be a function key
corresponding to a universal circuit
which has an encryption of f hardwired
inside it
okay this encryption is with respect to
a standard symmetric encryption
additionally i also have two n
ciphertexts
okay so two for each position
two for each input positions and uh the
top ones denote encryptions of zeros and
the bottom ones denoting encryptions of
one and in the first one i'll also put
the secret key to help uh the evaluator
decrypt the encryption of f
okay and it's kind of intuitive to see
that if i want to now
evaluate the suffocation of f let's say
on input all zero strings then i'll just
pick all the appropriate uh
input encodings right and then just
jointly decrypt them to get f of
all zero strings right and just to give
you some perspective those who are
familiar with reusable gobble circuits
the reason reusable gobbled circuits
don't give a fusculation is because uh
first the input encoding is private and
second it's not decomposable so
therefore if an evaluator needs to
evaluate the reusable global circuit on
an input x he needs to go back to the
gobbler and get the encoding of x here
because we have decomposability that i
can encode each bit separately i can
give the entire input space encoded in a
compact form we're just using two to one
ciphertext and now the evaluator can
just choose the appropriate encodings
for his input and evaluate on his own
why does it work to just stick the
secret key in the first bit you can put
it anywhere i mean any of the positions
it's okay
so the f has
so the oh
so the key is put somehow for the
decryption function
but the decryption function composed
with f yes so so what will happen is
that uh when you put all these uh try to
decrypt them with this function key it
will first use sk to decrypt f and then
apply f on all the zeros
so yeah so the decryption of the
symmetric encryption is hard is also
inbuilt in you
okay so now let me uh show you how to
get uh mifv for nav functions from
compact fee
so the main idea is uh it's very quite
simple it's um
it's really true so
let me try to demonstrate it to you uh
so what i'm going to show you is an
iterated construction of nrvm ife from
compactfe okay so what we do is this we
take a secret key function encryption
scheme for singularity i'll just denote
it by mifv1
and also a public key compact fee scheme
and then we somehow tie it together so
that it gives us mifv for two area
functions
okay and then we just repeat the process
we take
this two areas mife scheme secret key
we combine it with a new instance of a
public key compact f scheme we again tie
it together we get mi fee for three
array functions and so on
until we get
mife for nre functions
okay so
actual procedure is very symmetrical so
let me just focus on the first step
right how to get mifv for two area
functions and then you can just repeat
the same process
so let me introduce some notation
the triangles are going to denote
function keys
rectangles are going to denote
ciphertext the color red will denote
secret key functional encryption and
green will denote public key functional
encryption
okay
i'll have this notation on the
next slide as well
in case you don't pay attention
so so i'm going to ignore the key
generation process it will be implicit
uh in the in the rest of the algorithms
okay so let me just start by encryption
so since we are encrypting for two
positions i'll actually i'm actually
going to use two different encryption
procedures for each position okay it
will be an asymmetric encryption scheme
so for the first position if i want to
encrypt x i'll just use the underlying
secret key function encryption scheme to
encrypt x okay very simple
to encrypt to the second position if i
want to encrypt some message y for the
second position i'm going to actually
generate a function key
for the underlying secret key fe scheme
and this function key is for a function
g
which is essentially a re-encryption
algorithm this function g has a pr of
key k hardwired inside it along with the
message y
okay and on an input x
it
produces for some fresh randomness by
applying the prf on the input x and then
produces an encryption of x concatenated
with y
and this encryption is is with respect
to the public key functional encryption
scheme
okay
key generation is also simple to get a
key for function f i simply compute a
key
for f with respect to the underlying
public efe scheme
okay and now decryption should be fairly
obvious right to decrypt i first take
the first two ciphertexts where one of
them is a key and one of them is a
ciphertext right i run the decryption
algorithm of the underlying secret key
fe scheme
so this will give me encryption of x sub
y x and y
and now i take this function key the
green one and i run the decryption
algorithm of the public efe scheme
and this will give me f of x comma y
which is what i wanted
so
sorry this one here
so for the first step
and that key together to get
x and y encrypted where did you get the
key to do that
so this is an encryption algorithm oh so
the public key for the public efe scheme
is hardwired inside here in g sorry i
should have i skipped that
so the public key for the
public efe scheme is hardwired inside g
so that's why it can encrypt
to apply exactly
yes
so the reason i use this public key is
because i want to
if i were using a secret key then i
would need to put the master secret key
inside g
okay
and uh it creates complications you
could try that but it's not clear how to
make the security proof work so it's
just easier if it's public key i don't
care right it's public
so yeah you're jumping ahead but uh but
even then i'll i'll
hopefully i'll have time to mention it
briefly at the end why why it's
problematic
do you need randomized functional
encryption uh no i'm generating
randomness by just using pr of key so
it's okay yeah
okay so since all the magic is going on
in the second step let's just look at it
closely right
why is uh the second ciphertext secure
right i mean i clearly must ensure that
k and y is hidden right the pr of key k
and the message y remains hidden but
function encryption as is does not
really guarantee that
the function key has any hiding
properties right so why is it the case
that k and y is hidden and i clearly
must ensure that they are
and it it is indeed an issue and to
solve this we are you know as you would
expect uh i'm going to rely on the
notion of function privacy for
functional encryption
and uh very briefly the notion says the
following if you have two function keys
for functions g0 and g1 then if they
have the same functionality on the pair
of challenge messages x0 and x1 then
these function keys are
indistinguishable to a polynomial time
adversary okay
now if you look at this for a moment it
will sound very similar to io ad and
indeed in the public key setting this
notion is in fact does give you io right
and the point is that in the public key
setting the encryptor can encrypt on his
own right he has a public key he can
encrypt messages on his own so you would
really require g zero and g one to be
functionally equivalent and therefore it
will actually give you i o but we don't
we don't we don't need uh this property
in the public key setting we actually
only need it in the secret key setting
okay and indeed in the secret key
setting uh
showed recently that
how to transform any non-function
private uh fe scheme in the secret key
setting to any function private one
okay and we are going to use this so
this is an unconditional transformation
um
yes
so so now that we have taken care of
that we can just repeat the process
right i mean
now to go from mife for ire functions to
my mi fe for i plus one area functions
we'll just repeat the process
for all the first i positions i'm just
going to encrypt using the encryption
algorithm of of the mi fee scheme
and of the secret kmif scheme and for
the last position the i plus one is one
i'm going to use a function key right
and
the key generation will be the same as
before
and
and now we will need uh the ir mifv
scheme to be function hiding but we can
do that i mean we can essentially apply
the same idea as in the single input
setting to get function hiding in the
multi-input setting as well
good so let's first try to understand
the uh the complexity of this
construction right i i mean so far we
didn't see why compactness was necessary
compactness of a fee so let me try to
demonstrate it okay so how many times
can we trade
so let's just quickly recall the
construction of io from mife for nav
functions uh so we had this function key
for universal circuit with f encrypted
hardwired inside it and then we had
these 2n ciphertext for each 2 for each
position now i'm just i've just written
them in our notation right because some
of the ciphertex correspond to actually
function keys i've opened up the
construction right
and let's also just quickly recall how
now how would we evaluate the sufficient
on some input let's say all zero strings
okay so let's just ignore the bottom uh
encryptions
so the way we will evaluate is
essentially by taking the first position
ciphertext running the decryption
algorithm for this right this will give
us an encryption of zero zero comma s k
right and then we just keep repeating
we'll arrive at this and then finally we
will get encryption of all zero strings
all zero string along with this k and
then we run the decryption algorithm of
the public efe scheme and we will get
the side output right
so you can see what is happening is that
uh this key here is encrypting
with respect to this key right these are
all different instances of fp scheme and
the i at the fe scheme the ith key is
encrypting uh or producing a ciphertext
with respect to the i plus one it fee
scheme right so now let's just say that
the fe scheme is not compact right
and that if that is the case then the
running time of the encryption algorithm
that's inside the inside the function g
sub i or g
gi at level i then it depends on the
size of the function g i plus one at
level i plus one
right that's what non-compactness would
would give us and if this is the case
then we can see that the size will start
growing at every level right
so if we just did one iteration of
course you know this is fine now let's
say we did two iterations
then the size of g1 will grow at least
by a security parameter right so k times
g2
we do one more iteration it will get
multiplied by k again right and clearly
after super constant number of
iterations you know it will not be
efficient anymore
okay
but if the scheme was compact to begin
with then we won't have this function
science dependence and we can go all the
way to
uh to polynomial in the security
parameter
right so that's efficiency and now let's
move on to security
so let me just quickly recall first uh
security of multi-input functional
encryption i'll just focus on two every
case this is sufficient uh to understand
the main idea
so the security game is defined
in a very natural way we have a left
world and a right world in the left
world the adversary is given let's say a
key for function f and two ciphertexts
x0 and y0 for position one and two
respectively and in the right world he
is given encryption of x1 and y1 okay so
to start with i'm just talking about
security for one message query okay and
in the secret keys in since we're in the
secret key setting uh the number of
queries do matter right
okay so security says
that if the output of f on x0 y0 is the
same as the output of f on x1 y1 then
the adversary cannot distinguish between
these two words right this is natural
because the adversary can obviously
learn these outputs so if they
themselves are different then you can
distinguish we want that if
that's the only way he should be able to
distinguish
okay you can extend this definition to
multiple queries so for example if there
are two queries then now we want
that the output of f
on the four possible combinations here
will be the same as the output of f on
the corresponding combination in the
right hand side world as well
good so let's uh start with a very uh
simple and obvious proof strategy and
see if it works so how about just you
know trying to change one cipher text at
a time right this is the kind of the
obvious thing we do and typically in
proofs so let's just try to see it
let me stick to it two and two message
queries per position
okay
so what we would want to go do is start
from this world where the adversary is
given encryptions corresponding to zero
challenge message
a challenge with zero to and we want to
arrive at this world where he's given
encryptions of messages corresponding to
challenge bit one
okay
so let's just do you know the obvious
thing uh let's just try to uh let's say
change uh the ciphertext here in for
challenge query one okay so here instead
of encrypting two zeros now we are going
to encrypt the messages corresponding to
challenge bit one
okay and the rest we just keep the key
passes right so now i claim that there
is already a problem
consider an adversary who ignores these
middle ciphertexts
okay he just tries to use ciphertext
for query one corresponding to first
position with a ciphertext in query two
corresponding to second position okay
and note what happens in the first uh
row right here he will get f computed
over x one zero uh comma y two zero okay
this is fine but in the second row he
will get f of x one one comma y two zero
so he's been able he's able to actually
pair uh a challenge message
corresponding a message corresponding to
challenge bit one with a message
corresponding to challenge bit zero
okay and uh for this uh case the
security definition did not say anything
right i mean uh this in the security
definition we only said that the
adversary if he pairs messages
corresponding to challenge bit zero or
challenge with one as long as the
outputs are the same he cannot
distinguish but now he's able to mix
he's able to do cross computations and
that's a problem that's really the main
problem improving security of of
multi-input functional encryption and
this is what we want to avoid
so our idea is uh going to you know
our idea is to use a different proof
strategy instead of going over each
cipher text at a time we are going to go
over one input combination at a time
okay so if you're talking of it2 then
i'm going to look at all possible
combinations which will be in case of
iot 2 and query q it will be q square
essentially combinations so i'm going to
go over all of them one at a time and
somehow ensure that the adversary is
never able to compute cross terms let me
be more concrete
so this is what i'm going to do
so let's in the left hand side i have a
ciphertext q ciphertext
for
the first position okay so since there
are q queries q ciphertext for the first
position in the second column i just
have one ciphertext which is the
function key for the second position
actually there are few of them but you
know it suffices to just consider one of
them
okay
in the proof what i'm going to do is
that instead of putting only the
challenge message corresponding to 0 or
1 i'm going to actually put both of them
in both the left column and the right
column okay so i'm actually going to
encode both x i zero x i one and
similarly you know y zero y one
okay
the next step is i'm going to use these
query numbers and actually put them
inside the the ciphertext okay i'm
actually going to encode them inside the
ciphertext
let me just call them indices
on the right hand side in this function
key i'm also going to add a counter okay
this counter is going to be initialized
to zero okay and when it's in is
initialized to zero
in the left-hand side in all these
ciphertext q ciphertext the second
challenge messages which correspond to
challenge bit 1 they're disabled okay
the cross is saying that they're
disabled okay g completely ignores them
essentially
now i'm going to use the following rule
very simple rule that if
this function g gets any input from
there any of the q inputs from there
if the index in the input is greater
than counter
then use
y0 otherwise use y1 okay and now note
that in this first hybrid the counter is
0 and all the indices are greater than
this counter 0 so it is always going to
use y 0. so this is fine right this is
what we want it to be and now but now we
can iterate right now we can increment
the counter to one and uh in the first
ciphertext i will disable the challenge
message zero instead of challenge
message one
now when i try to decrypt if i use the
first ciphertext then the counter one is
that is actually equal to index uh
to the index one and therefore i'm going
to use y1 so i'm pairing x11 with y1
which is a question right but for the
remaining cipher decks since their
indices are greater than counter i'm
going to use y0 and this is again good
because i'm using the zero challenge
messages there so i'm again pairing zero
with zero okay and now i can just repeat
this process right i can keep repeating
this until i arrive at
counter q and now i'm everywhere i'm
using y1
and pairing them with the challenge
messages one okay so this is essentially
it
uh to do this in index increment we have
to rely on function privacy of fe but uh
you know this
this is really the gist of the proof
uh yeah yeah i mean the compactness was
essentially in uh you know just
analyzing the size right but yeah
uh
and how many hybrids well if you are
doing nre mifv then you will have q to
the n hybrids
uh and since for i o we only need uh two
challenge queries actually we will have
two to the n hybrids right and this is
why we need the underlying fee to be
sub-exponentially secure
okay
so that is uh really it uh
that's essentially the proof
um
so i don't have a conclusion slide but
let me just say that uh what have we
accomplished all we have done is shown
uh how to get uh i o from compact fe and
really of the obvious question is to now
how to get competitor fee from some
weaker tools
again let me just stress that even
getting heuristic constructions would be
interesting just to improve our
understanding of io
so the search for io is from standard
assumptions is still on
thanks
questions
probably stupid questions but when you
started the construction in the first
place you you had functional encryption
and then
a wondering am i
i think right so one area mife is the
same as fe right i mean it's it's really
the same thing i just just to make the
notation consistent i use mifv1 but yeah
it's really the same thing
any other questions
do you think
this sub exponential io is kind of
intelligent
exponential fee
uh i mean given our current
understanding uh you know this is uh
this is really the same issue that comes
up in you know work of amit and friends
uh the point is that currently the only
way we know how to do proofs is to go
over one input at a time in this case it
was one input combination at a time and
there is you know some
argument to suggest that it might be
evident this this might be inherent but
there's no formal proof for it right you
can try to use uh come up with a fake
meta reduction to show that uh
sub-exponential hardness is necessary
but you know it's not a formal proof